[Music]
like my grandfather jacques cousteau
used to say the impossible missions are
the only ones that succeed and before
humankind had explored the moon
my family set out to explore the sea
that's why they launched the continental
shelf initiative a series of underwater
research laboratories the likes of which
the world
had never seen
[Music]
in 1960 my grandfather joined by my
father philippe senior set out to build
an underwater research station for their
growing team of oceanots they were kind
of like you guys
two years later conshelf was dropped at
a depth of about 30 feet off the coast
of marseille
a yellow steel cylinder 16 feet long and
8 feet in diameter
it served as a home and lab for its two
inhabitants for a week a short time
later conshelf 2 was dropped onto a reef
in the red sea where we find ourselves
today
[Music]
not only was conshelf a research
platform for marine scientists it was
also a human experiment to test the
effects of isolation and sun deprivation
six oceanauts spent a month living at
depths of up to 82 feet
nowadays conshelf 2
covered in coral and algae is teeming
with lionfish clownfish and beautiful
anemones the experiment proved that
explorers can live underwater for
protracted periods of time
but that the lack of sunlight made them
a little bit loopy
how long have we been down here
i i've
i've lost track
i guess you could say these submarines
are better suited for
animals than people
we are people
right
[Music]
you